I'm Molly Webster.
This is gonads episode five this week we're bringing you a pair of episodes.
This is the second one in the pear. Um,
they grew out of our reporting on x's and y's and all the different biological
realities that live inside of us in this episode.
They're calling them Dana's em. Hello? Hello? Hello? Hi. I can hear you.
Hi, this is Molly Webster. I can hear you. I got one of your working.
The other one's pretty low, but do you want to just turn the headphones around?
How is that working for you? Dana is doing something kind of historic,
I guess you could say. Oh, I can move and just to start us off.
Dana uses the pronoun they, not him or her, but they,
and a few years ago, 2015 or 14, I can't remember which,
I have memory issues.
So it's around 2014 Dana is filling out a passport application and there are two
boxes to check male or female. And Dana's like, well,
I'm not either one of those.
And so they wrote in a third option intersects
right. My basically apply for my passport.
Got talked to by the manager on the office.
It took me no side and said, you know, you cannot,
you get this passport and they turned me down and I
peeled and way you can appeal a passport application. Yeah too.
Who Do you go back to the passport office and say hi appeal. Yeah,
I totally get where they backed in the past.
What office and you know and I appealed
but the passport office rejected the appeal basically saying male or female.
That's all we got. Yeah. From there I found legal counsel.
So Dana ends up suing the State Department for a third non female non male
option.
So we brought Dana into the studio to talk about the State Department case and
while we were having our conversation,
what began to unfold like in their personal life story was this tale of words.
How words have the power to shape the world.
Oh boy.
[inaudible]
oh
[inaudible].
I was an air force Brat so we moved all over the place.
Dana was born in 1958 Michigan. Who was in the military?
Your Dad or your mom? My Dad for you was like queer or force pilot.
So it was in Alabama for awhile. Texas for a while.
Ma Montana for awhile. England for a while as a kid and I was a kid,
grew up with a bunch of brothers who were brothers and one younger,
like a whole pack of boys approximately 18 months apart.
But Dana never really felt like one of them.
I got teased a lot
when I started showering with other boys and probably like the grade started
getting teased
[inaudible]
about why size and looking physically different down here.
Uh,
cause my testicles didn't look like the other boys with it looked like a stuffed
sassy.
It was little didn't look right and Dana said it never felt right either.
Well it's always having pain p oof from when you were little.
Yeah. You know, going to the bathroom and those kinds of things.
Everything hurt. Not only that, but it was a close,
smaller, you know,
I throw a ball like a girl on the brothers tried to help Olin roller.
I was always trying to teach me how to do things better. G was my hair over.
Try to stick up for me, but to me the world was a scary place.
[inaudible]
uh, my dad was always gone flying and he was kind of a scary figure.
My mother,
she had a backhand that wouldn't quit and she never played tennis.
And Dana says,
for some reason their parents always kept a close watch on them. Like,
remember once in Childhood Hood?
Uh,
we were living in Arkansas and the girl next door had nose cut out Barbie Ball,
the hall close. And you know, we're, he had cardboard, barbies.
She has those and we're playing with ours.
She and I and my dad caught us. Hmm.
I got my, my butt spite. And boys don't play with dolls. Hmm.
My brothers were able to do things similar to the hat,
but I wasn't allowed to.
Oh,
so you think like if your brother was playing the paper dolls with the neighbor,
it would've been a different response. Did you have any idea? Like why?
Nope, I knew something was different. I just had no words.
My world was very small
and I think you could say it was partially because of that smallness in an
effort to make the world like a little bit bigger.
In 1978 at 20 [inaudible] I joined the Navy
[inaudible] you did.
That's so interesting because I would think that you would run away from the
military after your dad was in year four instead of one of the decisions,
but Oh, you went off of it.
Yeah. [inaudible]
to some 60 Americans are now beginning the sixth day of captivity,
improve their golf and then a small group of islands of the age of Antarctica,
Antarctic islands. And then I did three tours.
Every yard story exchanges, brocade,
they route hours. How did it feel to be,
to be part of the military or at least away from home and away from your
siblings and your parents?
Uh, it felt fairly good. I felt a little free,
free, a free to the confines and, well,
a couple things happened when I was in the navy about five years in.
First people started thinking I was gay.
Not that I did anything to encourage that. I didn't date anybody.
I didn't do anything. Or do you remember how that started or why? Well,
because I was so small,
I didn't go out drinking and trying to pick up women with the guys.
And there was somebody on board,
my first ship who I guess was putting books and magazines on my rack,
very gay context, gay porn or something explicit gay porn.
And some books
you could think that leaving gay porn on someone's bed or bookshelf is not that
big of a deal or it's some sort of like initiation thing or something. Um,
but this was at a time
before, don't ask, don't tell where if you were gay, you were kicked out.
And so I got caught up in witch hunts,
you know, at one point the NIS,
which is a precursors to the MCIS, the National Institute of Security,
Navy intelligence.
Oh, okay. So called, give me another acronym on nail it.
Anyway, uh, so they infuriated me about, you know,
who I was dating, who I had sex with. Yeah. You know,
those kinds of things.
And then while all that was happening when I was in Beirut on my second tour,
late fall 1982,
Dana was working below deck doing some paperwork in a noisy fan room and an
announcement when out on the ship that said that they're going to do a test
launch of one of the gigantic missiles on board.
But Dana didn't hear the announcement because they were in the super loud room.
And then I get done my paperwork.
I opened the hatch to go back into the ship.
I step out the gun goes off firing a 70 pound projectile maybe 20,
30 feet away from my head. Holy Crap. Yeah.
And um, yeah.
And the Carmen basically white blood on my years gave me some aspirin and said,
you get your balance back and go back to work. Basically. Back in those days,
they didn't know about,
really weren't too concerned about brain injuries or anything yet. It's like,
hey, you just go back to work. You're fine. You know,
they didn't really realize how much screwed up you can be from them.
Dana says it. Ever since that time. I can't,
I have a hard time looking backwards and telling time.
Needless to say, after the witch hunts and the brain injury a
re up when I'm like, no, you know what?
When I got out, you know, four years after I got out, I think it was,
or a little bit longer, I started going to Colorado State University.
I was about 30 years old when I started college.
During their first semester,
Dana was in a poetry class and Dana says something in the words of those poets
and in the class discussion, push them to go see the college therapist.
I walked in and said, well, you know, I, I'm,
I think I'm depressed and I'm thinking I'm gay,
gay. [inaudible]
tell me more about the, why you thought you were gay. Well, um,
two things. Um,
all that confusion going on in my mind that, you know,
am I a boy or girl kind of things.
I don't really know what the hell is going on with me anyway.
Dana says that he didn't really feel like a boy, like the way other boys do.
They kind of felt like an off kilter kind of boy and what do you call that?
And then all these witch hunts in the navy got really thorough thinking about,
uh, whether I was or not.
Like maybe those guys were seeing something that Dana couldn't see it.
That that was true.
I thought, well I must be a gay man cause I didn't know anything else.
I didn't know how any other term we had gay, lesbian,
bisexual and we had crossdressers. Oh yeah.
When you say you're like, okay, out of those options,
which one feels the most like me?
Tyler was the one I thought was the best option that I was.
So I went the gay male and you know,
I didn't date anybody but the therapist that Dana saw ended up recommending that
they go join this group on campus. It was the gay lesbian alliance,
which later became the gay, lesbian and bisexual alliance. You know,
because that's how long ago it was. This would have been 1989 ish. Yeah.
Walking into that group. What is that? Here I am.
What did it feel like t two here you are.
Was pounding like, man, you know,
I didn't know what to expect. And they just said, oh welcome, have a seat.
You didn't ask how are you dating or your fuck or anything like that.
Those would be some hard first question I think I'd run if someone started a
conversation with that fossil went through my mind is like, you know,
you thought there was like an entry visa where you had to like sign off on
certain things? Yeah, yeah.
But they were very welcoming and I thought, well you know,
at least there is a place that I can hang out where people except me for being
different
within a short while. Dana is not just going to meetings,
but it's protesting with the group because around that time,
something called amendment two was proposed in Colorado.
The amendment bans or repeals any state or local law that protects homosexuals
from discrimination. A amendment to where was up in Colorado.
So we got our shelves pretty organized.
I went to the Larimer County Republican convention thing. Oh my God.
Really? Did you speak? I tried to got booed off the stage. Oh, so you,
so you became something of an activist? Yeah,
I was a spokesman for the student alliance. Oh,
so you really found a home there. That felt pretty good.
That's what I started from waking up or being woke or whatever the term is.
You start, you're starting to,
I know I'm a lot more woke now than I was then. Um,
it was like I got my first sip of coffee and the caffeine started or like, okay,
activate your brain. You're like, oh, the world looks so different.
So many colors. Yeah. There was one problem though,
living as a gay man as I was at that time.
Dana was not gay. No. They felt at home as a gay man,
but they were mostly attracted to women and towards the end of college in their
late thirties.
Well,
I was an art school working in the fibers department doing my studio classes and
this morning when he kept coming in and watching me work,
she got the Romy, I got to know her and we started dating.
We got married. Really? Yeah.
Wow. You went all the way to marriage. Yup. And this is in,
this is early arts or like late night
two. Okay. 2007 we got divorced five years.
Yeah. Didn't work out. We both had issues. We weren't dealing with.
Dana says this period of their life up through the marriage and through the end
of it, it was very confusing.
They were just trying to figure out where they stood and they were trying out
all these terms like fuss, show,
also true trans woman.
How did that idea get into the room?
Well,
because I mean I was hearing more and more about trans people and starting to
read a little bit about it. And so I'm like, well, maybe. Maybe.
And why did that feel more true than gay male or straight male?
Because I, I knew this, uh,
there was a feminine quality about myself that I had to recognize. Okay.
So I thought, well, if I'm not a man,
I must be a woman in New York. Kind of.
I thought it was going to be a trans woman,
meaning to Dana, a person who was born male, but identified as a woman. Right?
So you're like, holy crap. So you were like,
hm, that's so interesting that like, well, that's where I went. You know,
I can't explain how. Yeah, it's just, it's,
it's um, like in Oh,
in a world where there's limited words, you're just,
you're just trying to figure out the word that fits you. Right.
It's like these small steps towards a truth.
[inaudible] so, yeah, after the divorce, I'm, I'm looking,
uh, myself insane. Okay.
What's going on here with me? This isn't working.
What Dana discovers after the break.
So, cool.
Hi, this is Annette calling from New Castle California. Radiolab presents go.
NADS is supported in part by science sandbox assignment's foundation initiative
dedicated to engaging everyone in the process of science.
Additional support for radio lab was provided by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation.
My life before hip. I was just pain like sickle cell was my life for forever
the rapper prodigy inspired pop and hip hop legends. But what inspired him?
I liked the angle to hip hop. It helped me get my aggression out.
I'm Christopher Johnson and I'm Mary Harris.
The realness is a new podcast from wny c studios that takes you inside
prodigies, legendary music.
And it asks why the iconic rapper couldn't escape a single recessive gene.
Listen and subscribe to the realness wherever you get your podcasts.
We're back. Episode Five, the story of Dana Zim. At this point,
Dana is divorced and feeling really unsure about who they are.
They tried boy, girl, trans, bi, um,
gay male and marriage and none of it seemed right.
It's really just shoveled. I was really, I was crying. I was like,
I wasn't taking care of myself.
[inaudible]
Dana says at this point,
Woo.
He started to really wonder where is all this confusion coming from?
Oh, I started digging deeper. Okay. A lot of stuff was going on.
What happened to me as a child?
[inaudible]
Dana had always had these like memories.
Some of them hazy of having surgery as a kid, being like three, four, five,
six and being in hospital.
Um, so I was pretty much there alone most of the time. Uh,
my grandparents visited remain once. My Dad was there once.
How many surgeries do you think there were? I don't know. Wow.
But more than definitely more
than one. Between three and six years, all I had multiple,
I just don't know how many
Dana only had like tiny fragments of these memories.
I mean it's hard to remember anything when you're three anyways,
but now in their fifties Dana started to look back and wonder what were those
surgeries also.
Does that explain why I feel so different down there and like why I'm in pain
Britain that point I was in such pain that I was walking bull legged trying to
keep it. Anything from touching it. Huh?
That's why I started looking up penis surgeries and we were trying to figure out
what happened there.
Oh, so you're like, okay, I don't know what happened to me as a kid,
but I knew I had this pain and I know I have these surgeries,
so maybe they're connected.
Right. So I started looking up that look global.
A lot of different diagrams on penis surgeries,
all these different types and there's thousands of different fetal surgeries and
I'm like, shit,
I didn't know there was that many rock tie off dysfunction surgeries,
penis farms in our Cape looking in and I'm like,
I'm just trying to match up the scar tissues, you know, that was your approach.
How am I approach?
Oh you must have seen some gnarly photos. Yeah.
And while searching all these photos on the Internet,
Dana did start to see images where the scar tissue,
like the patterns of the scars looked familiar.
That's why I found this term,
Eh, intersex
intersects in my, it just popped up on the screen,
pops up on one of the surgery, things intersects on my,
what the hell is that? So I typed in,
intersects over your whole unit and that was full of information and intersects
and
mills are really starting to go off reign in my head going oh maybe.
Yeah.
And I was just starting therapy at the VA hospital up in Cheyenne,
Wyoming.
She convinced me to go see a year old news at the Ba and he confirmed guessing
DDI was intersects
[inaudible]
what, what does intersex actually even mean in your case?
Cause it can mean a lot of things. Like what did,
what did the doctors say to you?
You told me I was born with them as genitalia and that they can structured
basically my galitary org male.
In other words like Dana wasn't born with what the doctors would consider male
or female genitalia. It was like they had something that seemed to be there,
an enlarged cliteracy or maybe a small penis.
It was unclear and maybe there was a little bit of a vaginal opening.
Um, in Dana's case and as is often the case with, uh,
babies that are born this way, parents don't really know what to do.
And the doctor will basically say, well, you got to pick one.
And they picked male.
I exactly
who made that decision. I think it was my father [inaudible] who said,
you're not going to cut that off. Looks like a penis. To me,
that sounds like my father. But anyway,
the doctors,
they constructed a peanut should have been a large clutters probably.
And that was it. How old were you at this point when you figured all this out?
50. You were 50 and I'm 60 now. 10 years ago.
Whoa.
You were five zero when you finally found out that you were intersex? Yep.
Dana says when they figured all this out,
they had to like simultaneous feelings. One
I would, I was living.
Why didn't my parents tell me why?
Just basically lie into my whole life. Did you call them? Yes.
What did your mom say? Uh, not much.
She basically was angry back at me. She said,
your boy, you're always be a boy.
Was Your father still alive when you found out about the intersects?
Oh yeah, I called him too. And what did he say?
He human heart a lot and Kinda said he was sorry. Uh,
which is where we start reconciling.
Did he explain where he was coming from at all when you were no.
No, not really. But you know,
I had to learn how to forgive myself for all my anger with my parents and
forgive them as well.
But Dana says that like amidst processing that, right?
Oh, is she actually your fork
[inaudible]
for almost a year.
Can you tell me about the euphoria? Why?
Just because I finally had an answer. I mean,
it was the question I had asked and wondered about my entire life up to that
point. The question being do my boy or girl.
And the answer is yes. Both. Yes.
So as you foreign, what is euphoria feel like to you?
Walking on air.
I know [inaudible] I had to break the binary or for race out.
That was break the pioneer three. Yeah. Alright. Okay.
If I'm not a man, I'm not a woman.
I must be intersex or home Rafa night.
And that works.
[inaudible]
but it's not a question I should've been asking. I was like, who am I?
And those kinds of things. But
you're saying the question you should've been asking is who am I not,
am I a boy or girl
and why and why I at, why I here? And those kinds of things.
Those are the questions,
the kind of question most people ask.
What Dana means is that those are the kinds of questions most people get to ask,
but they were so forced into like wondering if they were a boy or a girl that
they never got to get to like the big existential life questions that most of
us, you know, wrestle with.
They were just way back at ground zero or was stuck there.
But I got on stock.
What does it mean to like find a word that explains you? Uh,
or so cool. Um,
okay.
Yeah. Um,
I think it was probably the happiest times in my life.
You now identify as eh, or Herm Intersex,
non-binary Queer. Yup.
Is there anything in that that,
do you feel like fully free and found and sort of euphoric and you now or is
there anything that still feels confining?
No, they pretty much as I am, I just had a tee shirt made up.
So is that Bruce's, you know, AAF at the bottom of it.
Hi, I'm Intersex, non-binary, queer as fuck as fuck.
Or in Bali. I don't know. Venture sex,
non binary queer as fuck you like. That's pretty much it.
I got to put on a t shirt, hope, nothing else changes and our socks.
Non Binary Queer as fuck. Oh how are you going to put that? Yeah.
Her sex non binary. Queer as fuck.
Since discovering intersects 10 years ago,
Dana's become involved in the community,
a rapping and traveling to conferences.
That's actually what kicked this whole passport thing off.
And on May 29th of this year,
Dana and the State Department were back in front of a judge arguing the case on
its constitutional merits. No decision has been made.
Dana's lawyers think we could see one this fall since Dana's case began.
Now five states in Washington DC have non-gendered identification documents with
more states proposed
special thanks for this episode. Go to Paula stone, Williams,
Kathy to Matt Collette, Lambda Legal and Jerry Callahan.
This episode was reported by me,
Molly Webster and co-produced by Jad Abumrad with production help from Rachel
[inaudible] and editing by Pat Walters.
Our word played music was written, performed,
and produced by major Connery and Alex Overington
[inaudible].
And before you go, we'd love you to sign up for our newsletter.
You can do that by going to radio lab.org/newsletter or text gonads to
seven zero one dash zero one that's gonads two seven zero one dash zero one
see ya.
Hi, this is James van from Denver, Colorado.
Radiolab was created by Java boom rod and is produced by Soren Wheeler.
Dylan Keefe is our director of sound design. Bria Matasar.
Pedea is our managing director. Our staff includes Simon Adler,
Maggie Bartolome, Becca Bressler, Rachael Cusick, David Gevo,
Bethel [inaudible], Tracy hunt, not kilty. Robert Krulwich, Annie Mcewen, Latif,
NASA, Melissa O'Donnell, Arianne Wack, Pat Walters,
and Molly Webster with help from Shima [inaudible] Carter Hodge and Reesie Agar.
Our fact checker is Michelle Harris.